(audience cheering)
- I know!
- Look at your pretty audience.
- I, thank you!
- Your audience looks so pretty.
- [Kelly] You look so beautiful.
- You got lovely colors
on. Very springtime.
- [Kelly] I know you do too.
But I love the touch of rock
and roll with the leather.
This is my favorite part of it.
- I'm always trying to be rock and roll.
I'm failing.
- [Kelly] No, you're not failing.
You're always rock and roll.
I literally was so
excited you were coming.
I was in all caps, and my emails with
my Executive Producer this weekend.
I was like, what?
I was very excited.
Anyway, it's great to see you.
Happy St. Patrick's Day.
Do y'all celebrate that in London?
Did you grow up with that?
- You not so much as they do in New York.
Funnily enough.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, I mean there's
a big Irish population
obviously in London.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- But, New York is where
they really celebrate it.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I think they
shut down streets and yeah.
- [Helen] Yeah.
That's, but it's in Ireland, it's honestly
it's more of a religious
holiday, you know,
St. Patrick's Day.
So it's not.
- [Kelly] Yeah, so you know,
they're doing it for the right reasons.
- Don't get me wrong,
they celebrate. Yeah.
- Would you like a
green beer to celebrate?
- I've never had a green beer.
- [Kelly] Me neither! I don't think.
Maybe I have on here, actually.
I think that's the only other time.
Yes. Let's do it.
Okay. This is Justin.
- Justin.
- Yes. This Justin.
You get a fancy,
- I'm not sure I want to
say thank you for that.
- Worthy of a Dame, your cup.
Look, I got the Average Joe cup.
- How'd they make it green?
- I'm, I'm sure.
- I guess they put dye in it.
- [Kelly] Maybe it
involves giving us cancer.
I'm not sure.
Anyway, cheers! Green beer!
- Cheers, sweetie.
- Take a tiny bit.
Okay.
- Wait a minute. Happy St. Patrick's Day.
- Happy Saint Patty's Day, yeah.
- Happy St. Patty's Day.
- Yeah, just taste like beer.
Yeah. Just your, yeah, beer, that's green.
- You wouldn't even know
it was green, would you?
- Yeah, I know.
You know what I just noticed,
I don't even know if
you wanna talk about it,
but I have a tattoo right
here on me, as well.
What, what does yours mean?
I just noticed it.
- Are you kidding? You
got the same tattoo?
- Not the same. I just noticed
it was in a similar place.
- Oh, wasn't it painful?
- It, well, it, I was very inebriated.
- Me too, me too.
You'd have to be, really, don't you?
- What does it stand for?
- Mine was done with a safety pin, which,
so it took forever.
- What?
- [Helen] It was like a,
yeah, it was a Native American
who did it for me,
and she was brilliant.
She just put a little of
cotton around the end of the
of the, you know, the pointy
bit of the safety pin,
and they just stabbed my hand with it.
It was so painful.
Halfway through I said,
I can't stand it anymore.
You stop.
She said, no, once you've
committed to her tattoos
you held my hand, you've
gotta continue, you know.
- Oh my gosh.
- She was absolutely right, of course.
'Cuz half her tattoo
would've been terrible.
- [Kelly] Would've been a little silly.
- Yeah.
- Did it mean anything special to you?
- It did actually.
It, it kind of, it's two interlocking V's,
which means someone can
be as different from you
as you can possibly imagine,
but have equal value to you.
And I thought that was
a very nice concept.
- Wait, that's the kind
of tattoo you get drunk.
What? That's not the
kinda tattoo I get when
I'm inebriated. That was very prolific.
I was like, wait, what?
That's incredible.
- My next one will be an anchor.
- Okay.
Okay.
So wait, we just had the Oscars Sunday.
So you, you didn't go, I know, I heard,
but like, did, did you watch it?
Did you, what was your favorite moment?
- [Helen] I did watch
it, I was in a restaurant
actually watching it.
They had it up on the thing,
so, so that was great to,
to watch that.
- Anything that happen that you love?
- I cried when Brendan Fraser got,
- [Kelly] Oh, it's so cool.
- Got the award. I cried.
- [Kelly] He did such an incredible job.
- [Helen] Yeah, I worked
with Brendan, you know
quite a few years ago on
a film called Inkheart.
And he was, he is such a lovely person.
He's the, I think you've
had him on your show.
- Yeah, yeah. I've had
him on a couple times.
- [Helen] And I'm sure you, you know how,
what a beautiful man he is.
He's a magical man, I think.
And he was clearly very, very moved.
It was a huge moment for him.
So I, it was the right person for me.
The, the way he responded to it, I, I,
I just found it very moving,
is, it was the highlight
for me of the whole show.
- I love that when you're
rooting for someone
'cuz you really believe in
like, what their, either them
or their project, whatever
it may be, and then they win.
That's a really good feeling
for everyone involved.
- Yeah, it's great, it's great.
- Yeah. What did it feel like
when you won for The Queen?
Were you, do you go into like,
do you remember, or do you just.
- [Helen] I do remember. I do remember.
You know, it, it's a
it, it is an incredible
moment in any actor's life.
- [Kelly] Yeah, to be recognized.
(audience clapping)
- [Helen] You know, at
the same time, you know
it's not like an athletic race, you know.
Usain Bolt wins,
he is the fastest person.
- Oh.
- [Helen] But you know what I'm saying?
In our world, it's not the same.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, we are, we are not athletes.
- [Kelly] It's subjective.
- It's subjective and all the rest of it,
and luck, and all the rest of it.
But, you know, when you get
to the Oscars, you've been
you've been to a lot of
award shows by then, you know
obviously. So, you know, you've been
in this weird carousel of,
of self regard,
and talking about yourself endlessly.
- Yes.
- Sick about talking
yourself and, and, and,
and it's the final moment.
So, it's a moment of,
it's a weird moment
when in a way this sort
of beautiful bubble you've
been in, swirling around,
this bubble of award
shows is suddenly popped,
because that's the end of it.
- Yeah.
- So it's, it's, it's a
moment of incredible sort
of triumph, is not the
right word, but, you know
you feel incredible.
It's an incredible moment.
I, I'm being very inarticulate.
You can cut it all out.
- [Kelly] No!
I think it's,
I, I am like anytime I,
I've never won anything
like an Oscar, but anytime I
want like a Grammy or anything
like that, my, sometimes I blank.
I just blank 'cuz I don't
think I'm going to win.
- Yes.
- And then you win.
- Forget every human
I'm supposed to thank.
Yeah. Oh, oh yeah.
- No, absolutely.
- I'm just like screw
it. Thank all of you.
- [Helen] Yeah, yeah no.
Yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] I just, I go kinda of foggy.
- I'm not good with
those list of thank yous.
You do go incredibly foggy.
- That's so cool though.
- It, it is an amazing moment.
It is an absolute.
And I remember thinking, well, this is it.
This is the top.
The only way now, is down.
- But slides are fun! That's what I'd say.
Your new movie is called
Shazam, Fury of the Gods.
So, what was it like
playing a villain goddess?
- Well, first of all,
I'd seen the first one
and being completely charmed by it.
I loved it.
- Me too.
- So when they said, would
you like to be in Shazam?
I sort of thought, oh yeah, that, you know
I loved the first one, so why not?
And then the word goddess came up.
- [Kelly] Hell yeah.
Well of course.
It's incredible, and I didn't know like,
you did some of your stunts, right?
Because.
- I did.
- [Kelly] I'm hoping
you didn't do the scene
that you just get, yeah.
Shazam takes you out, like a lot.
- I did do that scene.
- You did that scene?
- I did.
I mean, not all of it.
- Okay.
- But I did a lot of it.
- You get behind handed to you.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
But I hand it to him.
- You do, you do.
Try not to spoil it.
She hands it to him as well.
- I got my Shazam finger. This
is the result of my stunt.
- [Kelly] Oh my God. Are are you kidding?
- You, can you see how bent that one?
This one's nice and straight.
That's my Shazam finger, yeah.
- I feel like we have something in common.
So I bent, I didn't
break it, but I bent it.
So mine's bent too, my
other one to my, yeah.
- This is a lot more
bent than your bent one.
- [Kelly] Yeah, it does
look, it does look pretty,
who did that to you?
- A concrete wall.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Oh my God.
So that didn't go over well.
- In, in the fight.
I was hoping to hit Zach.
And, and the stunt guy
said, you must follow
through, 'cuz otherwise
it doesn't look good.
So I went, okay, I'll follow through.
You know, bam!
Right into the concrete wall.
So, but I was very stunty,
you know, which is yeah,
no it's fine. It's
fine. No, no, it's fine.
No carry on.
- It's like killing you
and you're like, I'm great!
- No, no, I'm great. I'm great.
- Oh, I would've been a baby about it.
Somebody help me.
Like I would've been
a total baby about it.
I love it though.
I didn't know the whole story behind,
we had Zachary here, and I
didn't know the whole story
behind, even how Shazam his name.
Like, I didn't, I didn't realize
like how the gods fit
into it and everything.
And I thought that was really cool.
Cause I love mythology.
- It was a great idea.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Because they were the Superman.
They were the superheroes
of 2000 years ago.
- Yeah.
- [Helen] That was why people told stories
about them, you know?
- Yeah.
- They did superhero-y type things.
They'd come down, they'd swoop in, they'd,
you know, they'd
- [Kelly] Save the day?
- Save the day. But do
other naughty things.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And, but they were the
superheroes of the day.
- I love too though the
characters that you played,
you and your sisters,
it wasn't all bad.
There was reasoning.
I like whenever you hear the
reasoning, like the backstory.
- [Helen] Yes.
- Yeah, so it was very, they're complex.
- Yes, yes. And I'm quite serious.
- [Kelly] You're like,
not rooting for them,
but you're kind of rooting for them.
- Yeah, exactly.
- You're like, well that's kinda wrong.
- [Helen] Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- They did a really good job.
- And the sibling relate,
there were a sibling rivalry.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- And we weren't.
- One of your sisters is a psycho.
That's Lucy Liu.
- Yeah. But she's not in real life.
- [Kelly] Yeah. No, no, no.
- [Helen] In real life,
we became the, just,
we became sisters.
That definitely.
Rachel, Lucy and I.
- [Kelly] That's so fun. Yeah.
- The minute we walked on set,
we just bonded, and
we're just great, great.
We, we are, we call each other sister now.
- That's so cool,
'cuz it doesn't always work out that way.
Usually chem, you know,
chemistry sometimes.
- [Helen] Chemistry is weird.
Yes. Yeah.
Great chemistry.
- [Kelly] Well, you're
also, and we referred
to a minute ago at 1923
with Harrison Ford.
So like, this is incredible.
I love
all of,
I love all the, there's
three different ones
you can watch, right? So I love them all,
but I, I love y'alls because I just,
I, I love,
One, I love that your accent
through the whole thing,
and I love your backstory.
And I love how it showed
kind of a different side
to immigrants in America
that you don't normally
see in shows like this.
Like in Wild West stuff.
Like, even growing up you
don't really see that a lot.
It was always just white
people, just like basic white.
- Well true.
An American play.
But in, in reality, you know, we shot
in a place called Butte,
which is in Montana.
- I literally live an hour from it.
- [Helen] No!
- I have a ranch in Montana.
- So you know Butte.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- Well, that, that's really interesting.
Beautiful.
- I live like an hour, like
higher up in the mountains.
- Yeah. It's so beautiful, Montana.
- [Kelly] It's gorgeous.
- It's incredible.
But Butte, you know, has
this amazing history,
old mining town as you know.
And, and you know, when you
look at the history of Butte,
there were people from Moldavia there,
there were Welsh guys,
there were Scottish people,
there were Irish people, you know,
people from the Basque region.
So that's, that's what the West was like.
All these different accents
and cultures and stuff.
- But that's what I love
that y'all did that. Yeah.
- [Helen] Yeah. So, that was very much why
I wanted to play her Irish, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah. It was very, very cool.
I'm like, look, I know that there's like,
there's one store in Butte,
and it's like Walmart.
So like, I love that Dame Helen.
- Yes, that's true!
- Has been to Butte.
That's where I go to get groceries,
'cuz where I live is like super remote.
So like, that's where I
drive to get like, milk.
- Yes. I know that Walmart very well.
I know it like in the back of my hand.
- Me too.
But I just love that
you've walked the aisles
of that Walmart.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's just outta like, it's
just outta pocket for me.